family acura the sponsor of this next
segment is a one-stop shop for quality
vehicles
and service rocky stop by to see why
they are considered one of the best kept
secrets
in town
my name is travis aguilar we're here at
findlay acura in the service center
uh the valley's best kept secret not a
lot of people know that we can actually
service every make and model we do have
master technicians here that are ase
certified
to service your vehicles we do
everything from
oil changes to tire services
all of your major services warranty work
um anything you may need we really are a
one-stop shop for your service needs
so we are competitively priced with all
of your local
you know fast lubrication or tire
retailers
we also do have a lot of specials our
specials are always up to date on our
website
finleyacura.com and we're always running
specials for senior citizens all of our
first responders and teachers
as well
so travis when customers walk in what's
the process like taking me through
as if i'm getting my car serviced
absolutely after you pull into our
service canopy
you'll come right in here to our luxury
facility we have very comfortable uh
waiting area
over here uh to our right and then right
over here you'll see all of our
refreshments and beverages the free
coffee
and ice nice cold water for these hot
summer days as well
[Music]
so to top all of that off i hear you get
a free car wash at the end of your
service
absolutely we have full staff to make
sure that every vehicle service gets a
complimentary wash
that is so cool and this is a brand new
car wash right we just installed this
state-of-the-art wash
last month actually okay i feel like
that's the icing on the cake
great service and a free car wash i'm in
come on down
thank you family acura for sponsoring
this segment you can visit them on auto
mall drive or for more information call
702
982 4100 or check out finleyacura.com